[Music]
hey everybody its charlie there's this
big long clip of Minka Kelly talking
about Titan season 1 when it's coming
out what's going on with the characters
what its gonna look like
so I'll play that then I'll break it
down and talk about the rumor about
who's playing Trigon on the series if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos I've
new giveaway stuff that I'll explain at
the end of the video too so here's that
clip this show is part of the DC
Universe yeah so DC Comics is launching
their own streaming service and they
will be launching it with this show go
awesome yeah
oh very cool what do you guys shoot it
in Toronto we just wrapped our first
season in a couple weeks ago oh nice how
do you like it up there I love it it's
beautiful city yeah great people great
food and this new show Titans
congratulations
tell me about dove dove is part of the
duo hawk and dove dove is the active dog
walking down
yeah dove is the avatar of peace Hawk is
the avatar of war they she balances
mouth it's not often you get to see a
love story with superhero so that's one
thing that's different from this show
than any other one you know what you're
right yeah you don't see cuz superheroes
have feelings too there's romantic the
fact that we're actually not superheroes
we're vigilante so you get to see the
back story of how we became vigilantes
what happened in our lives that broke us
that made us want to fight to protect to
protect the good of the people but you
have her own powers correct um I am I
have a background in ballet and
gymnastics and jujitsu so I'm pretty
talented so I don't fight and I got a
super suit and I have wings we have the
same background by the way just
coincidentally but go I don't have wings
outgoing I have 30 pound wings that I
wear that I can't fly because they try
it's as realistic as possible
well you can't fly cuz what I can't fly
because that would be not realistic you
know then would you have wings let's not
really so I take people under my wing
and protect them and I slice people with
them when I fight oh oh wow yeah the
fighting we all have our own individual
specifics
I love fighting and in particular is
like a dancer oh wow were you a dancer
growing up Japanese background uh not
really not especially not in ballet so I
had to oh that's probably giving
something away but um yeah anyway okay
okay but um I had to train and that was
probably the hardest training I've ever
done be sure to check out Minka in
Titan's later this year on DC Universe
so that gives you a pretty good idea of
what's going on with the series when
it's gonna drop
thank you very much Mario Lopez for
getting that out of her so biggest
things first they are trying to keep it
balanced between doing comic-book stuff
and doing real world stuff so like
watching Dov fly around with 30 pound
wings would look kind of ridiculous if
you saw the Hawks flying on legends of
tomorrow during the big four way
crossover when they first debuted it
looked kind of funny
[Music]
so why I'm totally fine with them
changing dove just a little bit so that
she doesn't fly and she uses her wings
more for cutting the [ __ ] out of people
like imagine all the tips of her wings
are serrated blades but then also
shielding people the same way that
Lucifer does on the Lucifer TV show
big difference tears because she's a
vigilante she wears a suit the wings
don't pop out of her back like Lucifer's
magic does exist there are some more
mystical aspects to the hawk and of
character they might introduce that
later on but it sounds like for when
they first debut it's mostly them being
vigilantes just being total badasses
they do kind of have superpowers it's
heightened strength agility speed and
regeneration so think of it as a version
of the ability is that Black Panther has
when he takes in the heart-shaped orb
without some of the mystical side
effects that we know of right now but
the title of episode 2 at least the
placeholder title was Hawk and Dove so
I'm assuming that that's the episode
where they introduced them because I did
a video for episode 1 in right now it
only seems like Robin Raven and Starfire
are the really big characters introduced
in the first episode unless they've
changed some stuff since they released
all that information but she talks about
the main thrust of season 1 so you have
this Church of blood
Trigon / Ark that they're doing from the
comics but the other big part of the
season is is it explaining why they
decided to be vigilantes why they decide
to become the Titans team the more
mainstream characters like Robin Raven
Starfire you know a little bit more
about them but like they'll explain why
it is someone like Starfire who's the
princess of an advanced alien race
chooses to live on planet Earth she
talks a little bit about them addressing
their romance now I think she's just
talking about Hawk and doves romance
they have a really weird relationship in
the comics it says like they won't get
too bogged down in the drama but it is a
big part of their characters like Hank
Hall is a legitimate crazy person and
needs her to balance him out so I think
they'll probably a couple moments in the
season where you have fight scenes where
he does cross the line just to show you
how over the edge he is but before she
mentioned that I actually kind of
expected Robin to have chemistry with
all the adult female leads on the show
because Raven is gonna be more of a
teenager so obviously she'll be more of
a little sister to Robin but there are
several adult female leads that Robin
has had romances with in the comics like
he's out of romance with Starfire he's
at a relationship with Donna Troy so
naturally I just like well maybe they'll
decide to have some sort of chemistry
with the Dove character but it sounds
like they might not go there I've seen
one scene or a piece of a scene with
Donna Troy in the way she talks to him
makes it sound like they either hooked
when they were younger or they wanted to
hook up but just never consummated the
relationship so if he's gonna be with
any of the women this season I'm
assuming it's gonna be Donna Troy oh
they'll just tease that out because
she's not main cast during season one
but she'll be a regular during season
two the rumor is is that they backed or
renewed it for season two but they
haven't really said anything official
about it because they haven't even
launched the series yet when she says
she thinks she gave too much away I
think that was her talking about her
character dawn Granger being a ballerina
growing up so it just influences her
fighting style so imagine Sarah Lance
being a little more graceful on her toes
with giant 30 pound wings slicing people
up probably the bigger detail if case
you missed it is that she reveals that
Titans will launch when they officially
launched the DC Universe streaming
service the beta is launching in August
so I'm guessing that that will run for a
couple weeks then they'll launch it
officially after they worked out a
couple more bugs but day one when that
does launch you'll be able to get Titans
so because everybody is saying fall and
technically fall begins in September I'm
guessing the series launches in
September sometime middle towards the
end of September before the flash arrow
all the DC TV shows come back when you
think about it that way that's probably
why they decided to delay the Young
Justice season three premiere because we
originally thought that they were gonna
prepare tightens around comic-con which
is like an extra month or two to air
episodes and they don't want to premiere
Young Justice till they're done airing
Titans so if you're not premiering till
September that means the Titans will run
for pretty much the rest of the year
into December
then they'll wait in launched Young
Justice at the beginning of next year
but they haven't confirmed an official
premiere date for that yet
like I said I'm just expecting based on
this evidence like them waiting to
premiere till after Titans is done
Titans ends in December you wait just a
couple weeks while everyone's on
vacation then you launch Young Justice
season three so just recalibrate your
launch dates for those TV shows if you
were wondering about Young Justice the
other big rumor that a lot of you were
asking me about is that there were a lot
of lesser news sites reporting that
Seamus Denver was playing Trigon or the
human manifestation of Trigon on Titan
season 1 we know he's playing a pretty
big character but they are keeping it
relatively mysterious I do believe he
could pull it off but if you've watched
the Lucifer TV show like he's the
he's an incredibly powerful but he walks
around looking like this it would make
sense that they would try to do
something similar with Trigon if they
were going to try and create a vessel
for him to walk around in the real world
or at least communicate with people
because you have to remember that he had
to impregnate Ravens mother so that
Raven would be born and used her as a
conduit so that he could enter our realm
in finalboss form so you have to imagine
that there might be a version of final
boss form Trigon eventually on the
series but I don't know how they're
gonna handle that yet post all your
requests in the comments below there's a
bunch of ant-man the wasp that I'll be
posting in the next couple of days
there's been a new round of that blast
ring giveaway going on I'll just keep
that open til I post a new DC so while
you wait for everything click here for
my Titans episode 1 video and click here
for my new Avengers for phase 4 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight